bien crea una lista de pasos ordenados
que resuelvan la siguiente ecuación y si
te das cuenta tengo aquí esta ecuación
cuadrática entonces lo que quiero que
hagas justo ahorita es que pausa es el
vídeo e intente resolver este problema
por ti mismo utiliza cada uno de estos
pasos y ve en qué orden los vas a
utilizar para que así podamos resolver
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí así que
no pierdas tiempo e intenta resolverlo
por ti mismo
muy bien una vez que ya estoy suponiendo
que ya lo hiciste por ti mismo
voy a intentar resolver este mismo
problema y para eso
déjame copiar esta misma ecuación de
este lado tengo un medio un medio ok que
multiplica a x 5 x 5 esto a su vez
elevado al cuadrado y a esto le sumamos
2 ok y esto es exactamente lo mismo es
lo que nos dice la ecuación que 42 que
42.5 ok de lujo ahora lo que queremos es
aislar es despejar esta parte que dice x
+ 5 elevado al cuadrado o visto desde
otra forma no quiero más a este 2 ni a
este un medio y bueno si te das cuenta
lo que está más alejado de este x más
cinco elevado al cuadrado es este 2 así
que para pasar este 2 del otro lado de
la ecuación lo que voy a hacer es restar
2 de ambos lados de esta ecuación voy a
restar 2 de este lado pero es que si
restó 2 de éste
la ecuación esta expresión ya no se va a
mantener igual fíjate que lo que tengo
escrito aquí de color verde me está
diciendo que estas dos expresiones son
iguales si lo que quiero es que se
mantenga la igualdad entonces todo lo
que haga del lado izquierdo lo voy a
tener que hacer también del lado derecho
por lo tanto voy a restar dos de ambos
lados de esta igualdad y de este lado
más dos menos dos se van a ir y
solamente me voy a quedar con esta parte
que tengo aquí de hecho la voy a poner
con este color me voy a quedar con un
medio un medio que multiplica a x más 5
x 5 elevado al cuadrado y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 42.5 menos 2 lo
cual es cuarenta 40.5 de luz ok y bueno
antes de seguirnos resolviendo en esta
ecuación como ya resolví el primer paso
voy a ponerlo justo aquí mi primer paso
fue restar dos de ambos lados de la
ecuación así que déjame tomar un color
un poco más obscuro y
justo aquí restar dos de ambos lados por
lo tanto voy a decir que este este es mi
primer paso el primer paso es restar dos
de ambos lados y es más déjenme
escribirlo aquí mi primer paso es restar
restar
dos de ambos lados de ambos
ok ya tengo mi primer paso ahora
recuerda que lo que queremos despejar es
esta parte de aquí antes de despejar la
x y por lo tanto me estorba este un
medio para quitar este un medio que te
parece si multiplicamos todo tanto el
lado izquierdo como el lado derecho por
dos voy a multiplicar esta parte por 2 y
voy a multiplicar esta parte también por
2 de tal manera que 2 por un medio bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que 12 entre 2 se
va 1 entre 1 se van y solamente me quedo
con x 5 elevado al cuadrado que es justo
lo que querían x más 5 elevado al
cuadrado y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 40.5 por 2 y 40.5 por 2
es lo mismo que 81 81 81 ok x más 5
elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 81 por lo tanto ya tengo
mi segundo paso para resolver esta
ecuación que fue multiplicar por 2
de ambos lados este es mi segundo paso y
lo voy a escribir aquí y lo que hice fue
multiplicar
multiplicar multiplicar por 2 por 2 de
ambos lados de ambos
ambos lados ok ahora vamos a hacer el
tercer paso muy bien ahora quiero que te
des cuenta que tenemos algo elevado al
cuadrado es lo mismo que 81 por lo tanto
estoy diciendo que esta parte x + 5 es
exactamente igual a la raíz positiva y
negativa de 81 por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer a continuación es acá raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados de esta igualdad
y me va a quedar que x + 5 que x + 5 es
exactamente lo mismo que la raíz
cuadrada que la raíz cuadrada pero
recuerda que tenemos dos raíces una
positiva y una negativa la raíz cuadrada
positiva y negativa de 81 de 81 y bueno
por lo tanto ya hicimos un tercer paso
que fue sacar raíz cuadrada y para eso
déjame ponerlo con este color lo que
hice fue tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados lo voy a poner aquí
tomar tomar raíz cuadrada
y cuadrada
grada ok y ahora voy a reescribir esta
ecuación para que nos quede algo más
ordenado es decir esto nos quedaría que
x + 5 es lo mismo que más menos 9 que
más
-9 de lujo ahora lo que quiero despejar
aquí es a equis y ya casi acabamos si te
das cuenta lo único que me hace falta es
quitar este 5 y para quitar este 5 lo
que voy a hacer es restar 5 de ambos
lados de la ecuación recuerda que tengo
que hacerlo de ambos lados para que la
ecuación se mantenga y por lo tanto lo
voy a hacer de este lado y también lo
voy a hacer de este lado ok de tal
manera que de este lado este 5 y este
menos 5 se van a ir y solamente me voy a
quedar con x x es exactamente lo mismo
que más menos 9 menos 5 y bueno eso lo
puedo escribir como menos 5 menos 5 más
menos 9
-9 ok ya con esto de aquí podríamos
despejar la x a pero nos piden despejar
a x lo que nos piden son los pasos por
lo tanto vamos a escribir que aquí me
falta el cuarto paso que era a restar 5
de ambos lados este fue mi cuarto paso
que fue de estar 5 de ambos lados y lo
voy a escribir aquí a restar restar
55 de ambos lados de ambos lados la 2 ok
y ahora ya tenemos aquí los 4 pasos y
solamente por diversión vamos a
encontrar los valores de x para
encontrar los valores de x bueno pues yo
puedo decir que x es igual a menos 59
menos 59 es 4 ok o en su dado caso x es
lo mismo que al menos 59 menos 59 es
menos 14 menos 14 y ya está ya tenemos
los dos valores de x los cuales los
ponemos justo aquí vamos a llegar al
resultado de 42.5 por ejemplo 45 es 99
al cuadrado es 81 81 por un medio bueno
pues eso es lo mismo que 40.5 y si a eso
le sumamos 2 me va a dar 42.5 y de igual
manera para el menos 14 pero bueno
recuerda que nosotros nos pedían los
pasos y ya los tenemos aquí
paso es restar dos de ambos lados el
segundo paso es multiplicar por dos de
ambos lados el tercer paso es tomar la
raíz cuadrada de ambos lados y el cuarto
y último paso es restar cinco de ambos
lados si nosotros empezamos con esta
ecuación y seguimos estos pasos en este
mismo orden vamos a llegar a la solución
de esta ecuación y bueno aquí ya tenemos
nuestros cuatro pasos por lo tanto ya
tenemos resuelto este ejercicio